ce soir là tout se passe de tout mailhac
car qu'est un losc lille mauritania qui
revient à la commision des ans a parlé
pendant la pause on le projette moi je
les ai pas vus depuis lost in
translation 2001 il revient donc c'est
de la comédie pee wee a fait plusieurs
films depuis en fait sauf que ben c'est
la preuve qu'il n'ya pas eu beaucoup de
succès avec les autres films qu'ils dans
lesquels on a pu le voir il ya eu 5 25
qui était tombé dans l'oubli en fait qu
avait été présenté au festival du film
de toronto
donc c'est donc un retour avec la
comédie avec rock the casbah où il joue
un une star donc ancienne star il
soutient que c'est lui qui a lancé la
carrière de madonna et il est à la
recherche d'une vedette d'une voix qui
va lui permettre de connaître une
carrière internationale pour une
deuxième fois et il se retrouve en
afghanistan et rien ne va plus l'artiste
sur qui ils misent qui joué par zooey
deschanel décide de partir ils se
retrouvent avec un statut qui joue une
prostituée dans ce film bref le film se
perd dans de nombreux détours pour
finalement en arriver à argonne steurs
et là il se bute à toutes les traditions
afghane
je sais pas un film que je vous
recommande c'est ce que je vous dirais
malheureusement on va attendre au
prochain film en se croisant les doigts
que la snes primestream chez nous la
qualité de ce film là reviennent pour
bien mourir parce que la chanson gloire
du 15 bois domaine ception on oublie les
films que j'avais aimé son film français
qui s'appelle ben omrane woomera ainsi
réalisé par françois favrat on retrouve
un frère et une soeur joué par laurent
lafitte et mélanie laurent voici un
extrait
votre maman s'était pas quelqu'un pour
nous
ça va faire 30 ans demain un moment t'es
jamais pensé que vous avez peut-être pas
devoir compter sur l'amendement qui m'a
beaucoup plu de ce film on est dans le
suspense et c'est donc un secret de
famille qui va se dévoiler une couche à
la fois c'est le frère qui va tenter de
trouver le secret de famille qui a été
caché par toute la famille pendant une
trentaine d'années et j'ai beaucoup aimé
parce qu'il ya une complexité est ce
qu'on pense qu'il va arriver il n'arrive
pas c'est autre chose et donc mélanie
laurent et laurent lafitte sont vraiment
excellents dans les rôles principaux
alors c'est un film que je vous
recommande donc tatiana de rosnay qui
avait écrit le livre à l'origine donc on
sent qu'il ya une recherche au niveau du
scénario et ça se traduit très bien
écrit très bien et puis un film avec
christopher plummer attendu au fait la
gueule si remember et c'est très
attendue parce que on aime que se fait
la main atom egoyan avait connu un échec
total
avec son précédent film au festival de
film de cannes alors on espérait que le
réalisateur canadien ne reviennent avec
un triomphe
la prémisse est intéressante look si on
est à la recherche d'un secret c'est un
extrait du très peu ce que tu as promis
de faire une fois ton époux seraient
décédés
c'est tout planifié pour toi tu dois
suivre ces étapes à la lettre il
s'appelle auto valley
alors c'est un film qui a beaucoup de
potentiel parce que l'histoire est très
complexe là encore le dénouement est
assez étonnant que tu fais plein air 40
85 ans part à la chasse à l'homme pour
retrouver quelqu'un qui a été marquant
dans son passé je peux pas trop vous en
dur parce que si vous décidez d'aller
voir ce film
eh bien vous comprendrez qu'il ne faut
pas trop en dévoiler
cela dit il ya quelque chose d'un petit
peu archaïque dans la manière de
réaliser
c'est un thriller qui auraient bénéficié
de justement d'un petit peu plus de deux
filles de raffinement au niveau de
l'histoire de la narration donc
déception et je ne suis pas la seule de
cette infime qui a été durement
critiquée atom egoyan donc ici il ne le
plâtre est la moins pour le maghreb pour
le mon père on verra puis elle vous nous
parlez d'un documentaire pour terminer
l'homme et son chien
oui c'est hélène choquette qui dans le
monde du documentaire qui nous tue porte
un regard sur les itinérants regarde
tout à fait nouveau regardez sa position
mais près de toulouse que les chiffres
éloquents disparaître avance dans la rue
c'est tout ce qu'il fait est que je m'en
débarrasser
justement chaîne de vie parle de la
relation des itinérants avec leur chien
que pour eux c'est souvent une question
de survie
mais c'est un couteau à double tranchant
parce que ça peut aussi être un fardeau
ça prend l'affiché seulement à excentris
à compter de demain on fait pour tous
ses films ce à compter de demain qu'on
peut les voir en salle donc alors sur un
régime 6 bonnes vagues le film français
que j'avais pris feu rue des grands
tours nabeul ce week-end devrait bien
merci très bien au revoir sans vie